South Korea's rapidly declining
population trend is starting to show
schools are closing even in big cities
like Seoul
and benefits like free Subway rides for
senior citizens are becoming
controversial issues as local
governments struggle to keep Public
Utilities funded
we're not asking for complete support
from the central government we're saying
the extent of the fair increases can be
minimized with at least some assistance
Asia's fourth largest economy has been
pouring hundreds of billions of dollars
in subsidies and programs to encourage
young people to have children
despite this the average number of
babies a South Korean woman will have
fell further below one last year to 0.78
when 2.1 is considered ideal
the population here shrank for a third
straight year as deaths outpaced births
as the number of economically productive
people Falls so will our national
competitiveness I'm worried about a big
hole in our national security as fewer
people will be available to serve in the
military
one study found that only four percent
of women here between the ages of 20 and
34 viewed marriage and having children
as essential about 13 percent of males
in the same age group said the same as
far as who should take care of elderly
parents only 21 said that should fall on
the children while more than double that
disagreed
with many young South Koreans struggling
with day-to-day career and financial
challenges analysts are calling for
Innovative schemes to tackle the problem
the government will also need to
strengthen social safety nets for the
elderly forecast to make up 40 percent
of the population by 2050.
Eunice Kim Al Jazeera Seoul